welcome to previous lead actress and
actor nominees Naomi Watts and Robert
Downey jr.
visual effects they enable us to see
aliens experience at the universe's move
in slow motion or watch spiders climbing
high above the city landscape for me
just a typical weeknight in the mid 90s
but today we all get to experience those
things thanks to those who create visual
miracles on film here are the nominees
for best visual effects for Pirates of
the Caribbean Dead Man's Chest
John Knoll how Hickel Charles Gibson and
Alan Hall
before Poseidon boy sure miss Kim
library Chazz Jarrett and John Fraser
for Superman Returns Marc Stetson Neil
corbelled Richard R Hoover and John top
and the Oscar goes to John no Hal hippo
child Gibson an Allen role for the
Pirates of Caribbean
wanted him to become a doctor in the
middle of production when the crew is
evacuated due to Hurricane Wilma the
choice of doctor didn't seem that bad
you know the the naysayer said that for
blind kids from the bronx couldn't to
make it in visual effects but but here
we are
hey uh first kind of gotta thank Jerry
Bruckheimer for entrusting us with this
great big project
thanks to Gore Verbinski your your vast
imagination your your humor your your
tireless work ethic and you know that's
why we're up here so thank you Bill Nye
thanks for being such a wonderful
partner and creating this character
sorry about the deeply embarrassing
computer pajamas but we think it was
worth it and thanks to the crew my son
likes Addison the pinky promise worked
okay but thanks very much I love you
you